my parents would not let me have this
game so I would like I'm gonna go study
I do not like scary video games I don't
like the ghosts in pac-man I hate her so
much
the only enjoyment I have is watching
other people play horror games before
the walking dead before a zombie
apocalypse became such a thing like
Resident Evil scare the crap out of you
dude there's some headless guy just pop
oh no Holloway oh my god okay sorry I
just reek jokes I thought that guy was
dead and you just lined everything he
just like rossum thing yeah but I'm
coming after you now do not want oh all
those monkeys okay go no no no please
right oh this game man I didn't even
like passing the arcade seeing that it
would creep me out as a kid I was too
young for this I mean dragon player you
play Dirk the daring Jude is quite
already yeah Oh short don't son of a
[ __ ] see usually they show them like
he's dead yeah usually do they not have
a dead I bet they censor this Center
knit oh ah damn it
okay ah see this is why you watch big
kids haha
when Dirk dies and sort of shows up as a
skeleton he looks so disappointed in you
there we asked that's the one number is
this really uneasy
did we make sure this was uneasy we did
but it's definitely censored because you
saw his dick in the arcade all the time
I love zelda and the Zelda franchise but
this gives me the chills
oh you can kid or what
blah okay look at his eyes he's coming
for you
I don't like this oh no 12:00 I'm right
okay oh yeah that's so sad they're
having like a festival and then kills
them all oh look the ground is shaking
right bro - shaking oh my god
I have distinct memories of when I was a
kid I really hated the rumble pack that
you put on the bottom and it would start
shaking when the moon was coming oh that
guy
whoa he's supposed to be cute but in the
darkness everyone's 4 I always thought
that guy was an onion oh man this is so
stressful I think I don't know what to
do I don't know what to do Oh
scientifically this is completely like
ridiculous the moon would never drop
that slowly it was not scary because I
think when I was younger the graphics
were amazing and now see like cones and
squares like walking around you want to
find another game that holds up for 35
years you better go to like monopoly or
tents which are both terrible games
they're not great yeah I think there are
a lot scarier games out now five nights
at Freddy's messed me up
[Music]